- [Sara] So, the way
that this is gonna work is
I'll open it up with a few
directed questions for you,
Gary, and then
after about, you know,
15 minutes, or
whenever we get really bored,
we're gonna move
into the audience
using the crowd mic app--
- Did you just say
that I was gonna be boring
in the first 15 minutes?
- Yes.
- No, I said that after we
get bored with my questions,
we're gonna move on
to audience questions.
But, I'm glad that
you brought that up
because I think that
by inviting you here,
especially to kickoff,
this is kind of where
we stop being polite and we
start getting real, right?
My first question for you is
kind of a generic question,
but, the question is "how
powerful is the combination
"of purpose and innovation?"
I'm asking this
because I think that
we need to hold
ourselves accountable.
Like, is this just another
cheesy conference theme
that doesn't mean anything,
or does it actually mean,
like, from your perspective,
what's the power in that combo?
- Yeah, it's both.
It's a cheesy conference
theme, and it's real, right?
I mean, I think,
at the end of the day,
innovation, purpose,
these are very clear.
I mean, it's kind of
like the value of oxygen
or, like, of course,
anybody who's sitting here
that doesn't think that
innovation matters or disrupts
or is a key of how
we evolve as people,
or that it's a
hell of a lot better
to have a purpose behind
what you're doing than not,
is tone-deaf to the
reality of what creates upside
both as a human
and as a business.
- [Sara] Yeah, so then it's
just about implementation.
How do we do this, and so--
- Meaning execution?
- [Sara] Yeah, execution,
implementation--
- So, I know a lot of
you don't know who I am,
unless you saw me two years ago.
I get a lot of flak
in the technology space.
I was an early investor in
Facebook, and Twitter, and Uber,
and did really well, and
have a lot of street-cred
in that world, and in
that world, all of them
are super upset with me because
I always say
that ideas are crap.
Ideas are crap because
I get 10,000 emails a week
from people that want me
to invest in their companies
and they tell me that they have
the greatest idea of all time.
Everybody in here has an idea.
The amount of times somebody
comes up to me and goes,
"Oh, I had the Uber
idea before it happened!"
Great, what do
you want, a cookie?
Like, ideas are
completely worthless
unless you execute
against those ideas
and you can sit here and
tell me what your purpose is,
but unless you go
and execute against it,
it's no different than
something like an idea,
which is completely meaningless
without fundamental execution.
- [Sara] Okay, alright, so a lot
of here do have ideas--
- Great!
- But, one of the
biggest roadblocks,
and we do want cookies, too!
But, one of the biggest
roadblocks is--
- [Gary] By the way, on that
note, I do this a lot.
That setup in the back with
the candies and the stuff,
that's pretty legit,
so we should clap
up the candy selection.
I'm into that.
- I didn't even see that setup.
- It's yummy back
there, I'm telling you.
- Alright, so if you
want a piece of candy
because you have
ideas, that's your spot,
but, what if
that's a roadblock for us.
Like, how do we get other
people onboard with our ideas?
- You mean
within the organization?
- [Sara] Right, because
a lot of these folks
are gonna go home in three days
they're gonna be pumped up
about the things
they've heard here
and, like Sam mentioned,
everyone's gonna say,
"Oh, you went to
that conference."
- Yeah, so, over
the last seven years
I built my family's liquor
store into one of the largest
ecommerce wine
businesses in America,
I went out and
started investing in companies
that did well, and
then seven years ago,
I decided that I was gonna
build a client service agency
to help the biggest
brands in the world
understand where
the world was going,
how to market, you know,
the days of
making TV commercials
and print advertising
are not dead,
but they're waning,
they're very overpriced,
by comparison to some of the
opportunities that we see
in Facebook environments
and things of that nature,
and the thing
that I didn't know,
because I'm an entrepreneur,
when I make all my decisions,
I just have to go home,
look at myself in
the mirror, make a call,
and then go and move.
I've had to deploy an
enormous amount of empathy
to understand how many of
you don't have that ability,
and, so, there's a
lot of different ways
to answer your question and
I used to be really frustrated
with everybody here
because I didn't think
they had enough
gusto to go home and do it.
Now, I'm at a place
where I mainly blame the CEOs
of all the companies
that they work for,
or the board, or Wall Street
for creating 90 day behavior
because everybody maps
toward their stock price.
There's a million
different ways to go about it.
Look, I think the
number one thing you can do
is actually the best
advice I have for human beings,
which is communicate,
whether it's your spouse,
or your children,
or your parents,
or something you care about,
communication is the game.
Figuring out how to
be politically correct
is not the answer,
figuring out how to tell people
what you believe the
company should be doing
in a respectful manner,
that's the game.
So, look, my belief is that
98% of the people in this room
can't do anything with
what they learn this weekend.
I mean it.
It's not fun to
say, but it's true.
I now work with
enough big companies
and I understand,
and more importantly,
the stuff that
I most believe in,
look, I think the one
thing we're all grounded in
is the end consumer's attention.
You have a branding issue.
We talked about
this two years ago.
I'm here two years later,
I looked at the Google searches,
I looked at the
social media mentions,
people still don't
know what credit unions are.
Like, let's cut to the chase.
You have a comms
issue as an industry,
let alone as your
individual companies,
and, so, the really sad part,
and we have
financial service clients
and alcohol brands,
and government stuff,
like, I work with this.
There's way too
many people in this room,
and definitely the
logos that they work for,
that use compliance as an excuse
for not doing what's
right in a 2016 environment,
and, so, what should they do?
They should tell
people what they believe
within their organization,
top, down, left, right.
The truth is, most
people actually don't know
what they actually wanna do.
We're living in a world, right
now, of headline readers.
The majority of people in here
that really understand
the tactical executions
within these new
communication platforms
are almost non-existent.
You might have
read an AdAge article,
or the Wall Street Journal,
about what's happening in
Facebook, SnapChat, Instagram,
but do you really
know how it works?
- [Sara] Or it's like,
"Oh, we'll just
hire a young person."
- Right, we're gonna hire
up a 24 year old, she knows!
- The problem with
that is that young people
are often inexperienced
with strategy.
- Quick question,
who's got an idea?
Raise your hand
if you have an idea.
Come on, I don't believe this.
No one has an idea?
Okay, I'm at the
wrong conference.
- [Sara] That
could be a problem.
- That is a big problem.
- [Sara] Gary,
we're gonna have to rewind.
How do you get an idea?
- [Gary] Alright, now look,
I think everybody has an idea.
Nobody wants to raise their hand
because they know that I'm
crazy enough to jump out here
and maybe punch
them in the face.
So, I have empathy to why they
didn't wanna raise their hands.
Go ahead, where were
you gonna go with that?
So, everybody has an idea.
Let me save you time,
they all have ideas.
Next.
- I wanted to let
them leave their hand
if they've actually
told somebody about it.
- Look, the problem is
it's not their fault.
I used to think
it was their fault.
It's not their fault.
They don't work in organizations
that fester an
environment or a culture
that actually rewards
that kind of behavior.
(audience applause)
Now, don't use that
as an excuse, though.
You know, because that's
the fun thing to clap on.
Like, yeah, it's the
man, it's the machine.
All of you should quit
and start your own companies
if you have such a good idea.
- Hmm, okay.
- Don't laugh,
I mean, that's what I did.
- I believe you.
- Actually, funny enough,
it was actually your Web 2.0
do what you love talk was
one of those big triggers.
One of the things
that's revealing,
if you think about it,
is we talk about purpose, and
I open this with this as well,
it's find your purpose.
What's the problem
that you find a deep,
intrinsic purpose
and wanna solve it?
If that means
leaving your credit union,
sorry CEOs out there, but that
might be one of the options.
- [Gary] You know it's
funny, it's the way,
it's funny how you
positioned my talk, right?
We're gonna get real,
it's gonna get uncomfortable.
My purpose, when
I publicly speak is,
to be very frank,
I'm just hopeful
that I can break through
to one person in this room.
I'm very practical
about how this goes.
I do think people get inspired
and think
differently in an offsite
and things of that nature,
but I have empathy
and understanding,
and understand
how the world works.
In an entrepreneurial event,
I actually think a lot
of things can go and happen,
they just don't have the
friction or the red tape,
but when you work
within an organization,
it's harder to make change,
especially if you don't run it.
So, I would tell you that
sharing content has worked.
One of the things
that I've seen really work,
like, now, instead of
pontificating and peacocking,
let me answer this specifically.
If you really care about this,
and you believe
in certain theories,
I would find these
videos and articles online
and I would share them via
email within your organization.
Chipping away, like a
woodpecker, over and over
with that content, has actually
brought a lot of change
with a lot of big organizations.
I also think things like this,
but on a company-wide level,
where you bring in people that
are thinking about the world
differently than you, with
senior leadership at the event,
has been a very
remarkable way to do change.
It makes me sad
that my company has done
two or three or
four years of good work,
sold a lot of
products for clients,
but we may move the
needle just a little bit,
and then maybe one
keynote that I do with leaders
moves the organization
10X, and so, I don't like that
because I feel like that's
overvaluing sizzle over steak,
but it's the reality of
how human behavior works,
so I do think,
if you have the power
to create offsite events,
or program information
to senior leadership
in whatever environment,
one thing that somebody took
from advice from
a talk like this,
she joined the
committee that puts together
the end of the year offsite,
and then programmed a bunch of
characters that look like me
and it was the most
meaningful thing that happened
to that organization,
they changed their behavior
and they're having
one of their best years
in 17 years right now as
a publicly traded company.
So, there's things to do.
It's fun to clap that
the man doesn't let you
and your organization
doesn't support it,
but at the end of the day,
we should really put our
big girl, big boy pants on
and try to figure out
how to make it happen.
- That's obviously
to the individuals,
but a question here
that's come through,
and I want you to
answer this to the CEOs
of these companies.
The question is,
how can they foster
more entrepreneurial
culture internally?
- [Gary] Force it.
Being a CEO is being a dictator.
Create the rules.
- [Scott] Simple.
- [Sara] More questions.
Bring it on.
- Sally, you're the CEO.
Make the rules.
Force everybody to
spend 20% of their money
on things that
don't have an ROI,
that is scored with internal,
are things that
you've never done before,
and reward people for
the behavior of spending
20% of their time
and money on something
that you can't measure or
that you've done historically.
You just solved it.
There you go.Go do that.
- [Scott] Simple. So just a
quick reminder, everyone.
You can ask Gary a question.
- And by the way, by the way,
I apologize, this
is important to me.
I'm the CEO of my company.
I have 650 employees.
I tell them that
they get scored on culture
and emotional intelligence
over bringing me money,
over doing the best work,
duh duh duh duh duh,
It is the North Star.
The North Star that
people get rewarded for
is how they play with
the other girls and boys
within the organization
because I like continuity,
because continuity
leads to speed.
I think speed is the most
important thing in business.
And then when we reward it,
where the nicest people
get raises and promotions,
even though they may be
a B talent, and the
guy who's an A talent
but is a little bit of a douche
bag doesn't get promoted,
that everybody starts believing
what I actually care about.
Because being a
CEO is a dictatorship.
So I make the rules,
and then I act on them.
So go do that.
- So just a quick
reminder, everyone,
you can ask Gary questions
through the THINK 16 app,
and they will come up
here on my little tablet here,
so if you have a question,
do punch it
through the application.
Do you have another question?
- There's no more?
I feel like--
- No, we're actually
running out quickly.
- Oh, I would love for
more crowd questions for this,
but I--
- One of the traps--
- Would you jump in the
audience and ask questions?
Because I think that,
you know, it might be.
- I'll crowd surf. (laughs)
- So let me just move it back.
Because I think a lot of people,
I see people
nodding their heads, like,
"Yeah, yeah, we do
have a comms issue."
What about the
folks who are like,
"The number one
problem in my organization
"is communications,
but I don't know anything
"about communications,
it's not my specialty.
"Or technology, I don't know
anything about technology.
"I'm an accountant,
I'm an engineer."
You know? I mean,
what about those folks?
- Well, first,
they may not be right
about comms being a
problem, because if they're not
experts in it or understand it,
they may, as a
focus group of one,
think that that organization
is not doing the best job,
but first they want to
be grounded in actually
knowing the craft
or what's happening.
I mean, look, there's
a lot of organizations
that are getting a lot of
ROI from their traditional
media spends and
things of that nature.
It's just that they haven't
put themselves in a position
to test direct mail, or
sales-driven organizations,
or whatever they may
be doing, against some
of the new behaviors.
You know, I think they go and
talk to their counterparts
within the organizations,
and I think they tread lightly,
which is like, "Hey, Catherine,
I know this isn't
"my domain, but have
we thought about doing
"these other things," or
"What are we doing
"about those things,
I'm curious as a consumer
"of where we're going."
I mean, again, it's just good
old-fashioned communications.
But I do think it's
dangerous when you don't
have cross-disciplines,
I mean, it's amazing to me
how all 650 people
that work for me
have plenty of ideas of
what the CEO should be doing,
but it's really easy to
say that when you're not
the last line of defense
and you don't have
all the context to why.
- [Sara] What's the hardest
thing about being a CEO
and trying to get an
organization to change,
culture change?
- [Gary] It's lonely. It's hard.
You know, being a CEO is hard.
You know, especially
when it's your business.
You know, if I'm a
CEO in Corporate America,
I'm a hell of a
lot more interested,
because even if
you fail, you still get
enormous cash
bonuses on your way out.
So that's interesting.
That I like.
Being an entrepreneur
of an independent company
like myself is, if I stink,
we go out of business.
And you don't get the bonuses,
and you don't get the accolades.
And you know, my business,
my life is
predicated on headaches.
You know, 20 minutes
before I got here,
I was in my hotel room,
here, it's so beautiful here.
I don't know if you saw
the ocean, it's gorgeous.
Everyone's having a good time.
There's candy for
days in the back room.
And what am I doing?
I'm in my room, dealing
with four major headaches.
Problem after
problem after problem,
plus, I'm an HR-driven CEO,
so I like to get
into the muck, meaning,
I really fundamentally
care about their opinions on,
you know, I'm
really the head of HR,
even though I just
hired a Chief Heart Officer
to really
enforce HR, but you know,
I could be on a
call in a couple hours
that's Susan, who says,
"Hey Gary,
Karen's trying to ruin me."
You know, that could be
like 40 minutes of my day.
(audience laughter)
So you know, what's
it like to be a CEO?
It's lonely.
Listen, it's really
fun to be able to clap up,
like "Yeah, it's the
machine, it's the man."
I stood in front of my
entire 75-person office
in L.A. and said, "Look,
just so you understand,
"everything that is
wrong with this company
"is my fault, all of it."
Because I empower
all the other people
that are screwing up, right?
So, you know, how is it?
For me, I love it.
I love the action,
I'm an entrepreneur.
It's my oxygen.
I couldn't do anything else.
I've never
worked for anybody else.
I don't know another gear.
It's my DNA.
But it's not that easy.
We're living
through the greatest era
of fake entrepreneurship
right now in America,
because everybody in
their 20s is popping out
and they're the
next Mark Zuckerberg,
and we have 99% of
those companies about to go
out of business once
the next financial crisis,
which I hope
happens soon, comes.
So that we can wipe out all
this fake entrepreneurship
and all this bull crap,
but you know,
but it's hard.
You look at the universities
in America right now,
that have entrepreneurship
at the forefront,
Babson, UPenn, they
have the highest rate
of suicide, because
a lot of kids right now
think that it's just so easy to,
like, when did this happen?
When did everybody
just think they can build
a million dollar business just
because you live in America
and you're 24 and
you have a hoodie?
(audience laughs)
- [Sara] Right.
- I should have worn a hoodie.
- Yeah, we were thinking about
wearing matching hoodies.
- But this is what's happened.
Like there's a
stunning conversation
because entrepreneurship
is very Americana,
it's very hot right now.
But being a
micro-industry celebrity,
it's crazy to me how
much the entrepreneur is being
put on a pedestal.
I'm feeling it enormously.
And I think it's dangerous,
because I don't think
people think they
can just be LeBron James.
I don't think people
think they can just be Beyonce.
I don't think they think they
can just be these things,
yet for some reason,
we're in this place right now,
where we think we can just build
these million dollar
businesses, and entrepreneurship
is a skill, it's a talent.
Most are born with it.
You can be better at it,
but to be a great one?
And then we have a crazy
conversation around income.
Like the fact that the
bottom of the 1% earners
in this country
make $400,000 a year,
yet all these 20-year-olds
think that a million dollars
a year is like the baseline
for maybe being in the game?
We are just completely
in outer space right now
on this conversation.
- [Scott] Interesting.
Someone's actually
reading your blog live,
while you're on
stage, so we got a question
on your blog.
It says, "In your
last post, you talk about
"using empathy to make a sale."
- [Gary] Yes.
- "How can this
audience use empathy
"in their daily business?
- [Gary] I think empathy
is the greatest trait
that I was gifted by my mother.
And I use it every day.
I think it makes me
a great salesperson.
I think way too many
organizations don't deploy
empathy, ever, and most of all,
not on their end consumer.
Most of you think way
too much inside of a bubble,
and you get into a room,
and you white board
in things that are
in your best interest,
but not in the end
consumer's best interest.
So empathy is
completely left at the garbage
before you walk into the door.
And for me, I try
to run my organization
and my offerings, and
when I sold wine, and when
I sell books, and when
I sell clients services,
and whatever I do
for the rest of my life,
my goal is always, how
do I deploy 51% of the value
of this transaction
to the other party.
And I use empathy.
I try to understand why.
This organization
needs to take a step back
and understand why
nobody in America knows
what a credit union is.
That would be the first
step to a lot more money
made for everybody in this room.
Not, you're emotional
to why it's not happening.
Not that it should be happening.
Not succumbing
to it's happening.
But understanding
why it's happening.
And then that would help.
And the way to do
that is to deploy empathy
and understand
what's happening in people's
day-in, day-out lives,
that isn't allowing us
to penetrate them
with the messaging
that describes
what we do for a living.
- What are some of
the techniques you use
to gain an empathetic
understanding of the consumer?
Like if you were
in the credit unions,
would you do consumer polls?
Would you go talk to students?
Or how do you
actually do that, you know?
- [Gary] Yeah,
that's a good question.
So I think what
you just mentioned
are non-empathetic
machines doing tactics
to try to fake empathy.
What I would do is try
to find empathetic people
and empower them to do shit.
(audience laughter)
- Pretty simple.
- Dude, I mean.
I mean, I mean it.
Like, I don't know.
You know what's
funny about that.
- I think you should
drop the mic and walk off.
- How many people in this room,
I want to see
this, how many people saw
The Big Short?
Great.
I literally believe that
marketing and running businesses
in America are going,
if we could keep this on,
it'd be amazing,
because I'd like to start
interacting with everybody.
I literally believe
that that's what's happening
with marketing and running
businesses in America right now.
Everybody knows, but nobody's
doing anything about it.
Like 90% of my
customers are throwing
their money
directly in the trash.
Like watch this,
this is gonna be fun.
Let's agree on a couple things.
Let's agree that this is
not a 14-year-old, aged,
teenage girl crowd, right?
Can we agree on that?
Good.
By show of hands, how
many people in this room
now when they watch television,
watch it on their time, not
watching it when it actually
aired, but
outside of live sports,
you watch on TiVo, DVR, Netflix,
you know, on
demand, raise your hands.
Oh weird, everybody.
(audience laughter)
How many of you
when given the option,
fast forward
every single commercial?
Raise your hands.
Everybody.
And even if you're lucky enough,
excuse me, even if my clients at
Toyota, Unilever,
Pepsi, are lucky enough
that you get a
commercial shown to you,
because I don't know,
you dropped your
remote control off the bed.
Right?
(audience laughter)
Even if that happens,
the second something
goes into commercial,
every one of you grabs this.
My friends, attention is
the only thing that matters.
Before you can tell me how
great your credit union is,
how great your sneakers
are, how great your book is,
how great your service is,
how great your jam
that you make in your home
is that you want to sell me.
Before you do any of
that, you have to have
my attention, and then
you can tell me your story.
The organizations in the world,
organizations in this room,
are throwing good
money directly into the trash
because they're
marketing like it's 2009,
2004, 1997, or 1972.
This is an old crowd.
And none of you are
consuming commercials,
and $80 billion are being spent
to make them
and distribute them.
Nobody here is
going home and carefully
going through their direct mail.
(audience laughter)
I don't know what
people think is happening.
I don't understand how,
you know your same
tactics aren't bringing results.
You know that that trade show
that you go to
every year and spend
a ton of money on,
on your awesome booth,
is not returning
the same results.
Yet we just keep doing it,
as if nobody gives a crap.
- Isn't that the
definition of insanity,
doing the same thing
over and over and expecting
different results?
Right?
- Yes.
- We've all heard that saying.
- 100%.
I'm sorry, people always say
to me in marketing, like,
"I'm such a distruptor,
I'm so crazy.
"I'm so this."
I think it's crazy to
make commercials in 2017.
It's not practical.
I think I'm quite practical.
I know that an enormous-
how many people here
look at their Facebook
profile and their feed,
and their page?
Raise your hands.
How many of you use Facebook?
Raise it high, don't be scared.
I just know you're there.
And I know I can
sell you stuff there.
Facebook is
selling billions of dollars
of stuff per month!
I don't understand.
I don't understand
how you think,
you act one way at home, right?
But then when you put
your suit on and go to work,
you have different strategies
because of the
room that you're in.
Yet, when you leave,
the fastest growing
demo of selfies on Instagram
are 45-year-old women.
(audience laughter)
- [Sara] Oh yeah.
- [Scott] Any 45-year-old
women taking selfies?
- Hell yeah,
cougar selfies for days.
(audience laughter)
50% of this room in 24 months,
is gonna be living in Snapchat.
80% of it doesn't even consider
using Snapchat right now.
- This is a great segue.
Who here uses Snapchat?
Gary, how-
- How many people here
have never heard of Snapchat?
It's okay, rise your hands.
That in itself
is pretty impressi-
you know what, in 18 months.
I mean, it's moving
faster than I thought.
Go ahead.
- How can credit
unions use Snapchat?
- Well first of
all credit unions today
have to decide if
they want to court
13 to 25 year-olds.
Do you?
- [Audience] Yes.
Great, well then you
better figure it the hell out.
(audience laughter)
Because I think
a lot of you did,
the reason almost everybody but
that one random dude
has heard of Snapchat
is because anybody in this room
that has a 13 to 22-year-old
anything in their lives,
granddaughter, grandson,
daughter, nephew, niece,
knows that that human
being lives in one place.
Their phone, and on two things,
Snapchat and Instagram.
So how are you gonna
tell them about your thing?
How you gonna tell them?
How you gonna get to them?
You're not.
And you're gonna
spend it on bullcrap.
If you want to get the 13 to 25.
Now here's the important thing.
I believe
Snapchat is going through
the same thing Facebook did.
It's 13 to 25 now,
but when we
wake up in 18 months,
and it's 13 to 45,
I have a funny
feeling a lot more of you
are interested in that 25 to
45-year-old demo just as well.
And that's where
people get caught.
You don't project.
Everything's predicated on
today, but it's really not.
Because if you
look at your behavior,
most of your companies are
marketing like
it's 10 years ago.
- But you now, there's a real,
I do social media consulting.
- Okay.
- And I have a
hard time keeping up.
- Tough luck.
- The thing is,
how do we keep pace
with technology and we satisfy-
- You work!
- member demand?
- Okay.
- Like sorry
that it's moving fast.
(audience laughter)
But Right?
We're all professionals here.
Like, sorry.
Like sorry that the
world's moving super fast.
Some dude owned 80,000 horses
when the car was invented.
He lost.
(audience laughter)
- [Scott] So true.
- Like tough luck.
Innovation doesn't
care about you and me.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- You think I'm excited to be up
at two o'clock in the morning
trying to figure out Vine,
like I did three years ago?
- I actually think you
are excited to be doing that.
(audience laughter)
- You might be right, actually.
You know what's funny?
You nailed it.
I am excited because I know my
differentiationship
in the marketplace
is that I'm willing to
outwork my competition.
I know that I got lucky, that
I wasn't born in
America, so I understand
how good it
actually really good is here
and I'm taking full
goddamn advantage of it.
(audience laughter and applause)
But, this is what
I hear all the time
and I know a lot
of you know this.
This is very pungent
to the 50 and older crowd
that I see in this room.
Guys, I'm not
interested in this excuse that,
"I didn't grow up with it.".
I didn't grow up with it.
I'm 40.
When I was 18 years old,
I'd spent five minutes
on a computer in my entire life.
I didn't grow up with it.
You didn't grow up driving.
You figured that out.
(audience laughter)
So, this excuse that
you didn't grow up with this
is just not an excuse.
You're more than
welcome to not use it
as a human being,
I'm not in charge of that.
But if you are in
the business world
and you are
disrespecting these platforms,
you are vulnerable.
- [Sara] Yeah, I didn't grow up
with it is more like
I'm just not
interested in it, right?
- No it's just that,
you know what, I don't
really give a crap, I'm tired,
I've been working a long time.
I hate that it's changed.
It's not in my best interest.
I spent 20 years growing in this
organization and
now I know something,
and now the whole
thing's being changed on me?
I don't like that.
I don't want that to happen.
- I want to connect a
couple of thoughts here.
- Let's sit there.
- Yeah.
(audience laughter)
Sorry, but let's-
this is the dangerous
formula that a lot of you
are going through.
I have empathy.
It stinks if you're in PR,
and you spent 22 years in it,
and you moved up
the ranks and you've
got all those
relationships and now it
doesn't matter as much.
I get it.
I'm not happy about it.
I just don't know any other gear
than dealing in reality.
I wake up every morning trying
to put myself out of business.
What do I sell?
And how do I sell it?
And who could put
me out of business?
And I'd rather do that.
That's how I innovate.
You know how I innovate?
I try to create
products and services,
and do behavior
that is the behavior
that would hurt me
if somebody else did it.
Because it's a
hell of a lot more fun
to put yourself out of business
than have somebody
else do it for you.
- [Scott] So I want to
connect a couple of dots
here from what
you've been saying.
- Okay.
- One, empathy was
about understanding
why something exists.
- Yes.
- And then we've
got onto Snapchat.
- Okay.
- Now I know the answer
to this question,
so I can bail you out
if you don't know the answer.
Why does Snapchat exist?
- Why does Snapchat exist?
Because communication
is the foundation
of how human beings act.
And communication has gone from
drawing stuff inside of caves,
to standing on top of mountains
and making smoke signals.
go read what people wrote
about the
invention of the telephone.
It was gonna ruin us.
We made it.
Right?
Snapchat exists
because it was an ideation
and a evolution of communication
within the
mobile device, which is
the single most
important thing in our society.
Guys, how many people
here within every 24 hours
including when their sleeping,
are always within arm's
reach of their telephone?
Raise your hands high.
Look at this.
Not 14-year-old girls.
- [Scott] And the
important part is,
10 years ago,
50% of this audience
would've sworn they'll
never get a cell phone.
- That's right.
There's 60-year-old
dudes in here
who texted a
poop emoji last night.
(audience laughter)
I mean look at this lovely lady.
She's got two
technology devices.
A phone and an iPad,
and she's 80 years old!
(audience laughter)
Kidding.
- Are you on Snapchat as well?
- But the point is,
and obviously I was
going for the laugh there,
you look amazing.
I'm going to
kiss you on the face
when I get done with this talk.
I want people to understand.
You guys know this.
Your parents are on this.
This is real.
How are you possibly
disrespecting this still
because your
organization doesn't support
digital spend or
digital native activities?
It's crazy. It's over.
I don't care
how you want it to be.
It's the way it is.
And by the way, you take
the negative view on this.
Let me talk to you about
something that's going on
in society that I know
all of you have judged.
You go out to a restaurant,
and you see a couple,
and they're having dinner,
and they're both on the phone.
And you just love
to say to your partner,
"Hey do you see that, how sad."
Right? You love that, right?
You love judging, don't you?
Right?
Here's what I see.
I see two people
that 15 years ago,
would've had dinner together,
would've sat
across from each other,
and wouldn't have said
a damn word to each other.
Remember those conversations?
You've seen that.
Couples sitting right
next to you, not a word.
So you know
what I think this is?
It's a blessing to those two!
(audience laughter)
It is!
I'm happy for those two people
that they can actually be doing
what they
actually want to be doing!
- True.
Sam, you got a question?
- [Sam] Yes.
Is this thing on?
Here I am. Okay, so
this is, we talk about this,
that marketers,
credit union marketers,
we just have to
get the story out.
We have this comms challenge.
But what I see a lot in
credit unions is that we do,
that marketers
are held to an ROI
and push this
very specific product,
that they have to
take that to the board,
it has to get approved, it's
like marketing by committee.
We are kind of
hamstringing our marketing teams
within our credit unions
that they can't just freely
post on Snapchat when they
wake up in the morning and say,
"I'm so jazzed to go to my
credit union, this is my story."
We tamp that down.
How do we shift that?
- [Gary] A, that's why so few
people know about this, period.
And B, you change
the rules from the top!
Like again, who's
a CEO in this room?
Raise your hand.
Geez.
One more time, just hold 'em up.
It's on these lovely people.
She's in charge.
It's up to her.
And by the way, I have empathy.
Listen, I've spent
enormous amounts of time,
and this is an
absolute bragging moment.
I've spent
enormous amounts of time
in the White House with the
President of the United States
to go through the
legalities of comms
for financial institutions
and other things.
There is plenty
that you can be doing.
It's a complete
and utter cop-out
to use it on
compliance and rules.
It's that you don't
understand it fully,
you don't understand
the ROI, and that's fine.
But there's a
very big difference
between branding and
marketing, and sales.
They have different functions.
And way too many
people think that
marketing and branding is sales.
It's not and sales is important!
I'm a salesman.
I'm a salesman who just happens
to respect what branding
and marketing does,
because it makes my job easier.
Because Nike and Apple,
they don't transact me.
These guys don't sell me.
They won me on branding.
I buy it mindlessly.
The other thing
that really pisses me off
(audience laughter)
Sorry.
And we talked
about this two years ago,
but I'm gonna pound it again.
We lived through
a four, three, two,
and it's still
lingering but not as much.
Missed opportunity by you guys.
We lived through a
three to four year window
where the main competitor banks
were the worst
evil in our society,
and we didn't
pounce on the moment.
It's true.
And so like, to
be honest with you,
that actually gives
me very little reason
or hope to think
that anybody here
is gonna do anything
about what I'm talking about.
You missed the
greatest opening of all time.
You just let it go by.
Insane.
- [Sara] But
I think it's still here.
- Not as good!
- Not as good but
definitely still there.
- It's always there,
but guess what?
It's gonna cost you a
hell of a lot more money.
Not as easy.
Like I don't want to
let them off the hook.
No rainbows here.
You screwed up.
- [Sara] Okay, well I'm gonna be
the Pollyanna and say
I think that the opportunity--
- [Scott] We're getting
prompted on mics,
but we can't see the audience.
If we can turn
the house lights up,
that'll help us a lot. (laughs)
- Okay.
- [Woman] Hi Gary,
question for you.
First of all, it's terrifying
asking you a question.
(audience laughter)
Second of all,
this is not my question
but it would be great if
you could run for president
instead of the
selection that we have,
so that's the next thing.
- Can you help me on this?
I was born in a foreign country,
so they won't let me go.
But I promise you I
would make a run if I could.
- [Woman] So my
actual question is,
I'm actually a
customer of yours,
I have bought wine
from your wine site.
- Thank you so much.
- [Woman] I actually bought it
the first time I heard you speak
and I went right
out and bought some.
So as a consumer of yours,
I follow you
on Facebook as well.
You have yet to reach
out to me as your customer
and ask me why
I haven't bought from you
in the last eight months.
So what do you do: A, to
listen to your customers,
and B, what do you do
to instill and allow change
from your employees
within your own company?
- So we've been
running data on remarketing
for a long time at Wine Library.
So Wine Library I haven't
run actively for four years,
but your second point
is far more important to me
because you're right,
it's all about scale ability.
Right?
Like, I can't do
everything myself.
I can't call you, necessarily.
So we ran data on remarketing to
non-returning customers
over a seven year period
from 1999 to 2006,
and the cadence
on the recall for us
is actually now one year.
Like, we were finding
that too many customers,
if we really
aggressively tried to get them
into the re-funnel within
three, six, even nine months,
which is where
I had it for a long time
and I think we went
to a year a year ago,
so I don't know exactly the
details on your transaction.
One of the things that we
did four or five years ago
is create a
thank you department,
'cause I wrote a book
called The Thank You Economy,
and so when you get
hit up in four months
it's gonna start
with a phone call,
because we think the
human element has much more ROI
than the email
element, and obviously
there's a lot of
ways to go about it.
But at Wine Library, we
CRM the 1.2 million customers
that have come through
the funnel through the years,
pretty aggressively,
and re-market.
We even did
something where I'm trying
to call my own bull crap.
We just did a
direct mailing piece,
because I always,
and I mean this.
I'm not a technologist, meaning
I'm not obsessed with
Facebook and Snapchat.
I'm obsessed with
the price of attention.
Right?
So like, direct
mail is expensive.
I guess the stamp
went down two cents,
but I'm always triple checking
if it's still ROI positive.
But to answer your question,
on the VaynerMedia
side where we work B to B,
we have 100, 200-point
customers that we work with
and we kind of
watch their social.
What do they care about?
We stay very high touch.
On the wine e-commerce business
that has a hell of
a lot more customers,
our remarketing when
they're out of session starts
at one year and gets more
aggressive at
the two year point.
But what's even
more interesting,
and I'll add onto your question
'cause it's the
right energy of a question,
what we're doing with people
that are in the cycle lately
has been even more fascinating.
Which is, we are triple
downing on using technology
as a gateway drug
to human interaction.
So we're spending
a ton of time now
mapping people's
Instagram and Twitter accounts,
figuring out
what they care about,
and then using that
as a proxy to get them
into a phone call conversation.
Like actually,
what would it look like
if we had 80 phone
people that used technology
and big data to create
more meaningful relationships,
knowing your key events?
One of the things
I'm building right now,
it's actually done,
I'm just testing it
is on your
account at Wine Library,
if you want to give it to me,
and we're gonna ask for
it very black and white.
No tricks, no games,
we're gonna say,
"Hey, we'd like to know the
birthdays and biggest events
in your life, and if
you want to give them to us,
the 10 days leading up to it,
we will give you
recommendations on wine
and free shipping,
predicated on anniversaries,
birthdays,
things of that nature.
And plenty of people will think
that's creepy and privacy,
way more are gonna
think it's a service and good.
And so, hacking away.
Hacking away.
- [Scott] It's an
interesting flip on that,
and so I've done a lot of work
in the financial services sector
on the negative side of this.
And so insurance is the
one I know the best, worst.
Insurance has such a negative
conversation with the market,
to the point where the
research I did in the U.S.
most insurance
policy holders only speak
to their provider maybe
1 to 1.1 times a year.
75% of those
discussions are negative.
So, it means it's a claim, a
complaint, or a cancellation.
That's what you get when
you think about insurance.
Even as a consumer, you have
a very negative perception
of that brand, so every
time you speak to that brand,
it's like
asking Gary a question.
(audience laughter)
- Look, there's another
thing that's emerging, guys.
Which is, time is
becoming the number one asset.
Right?
Besides health and
well-being and money,
time is emerged as one of the
core things in our pillar.
So, one of the crazy
things, back to the phone thing
that's interesting,
that we're trying to do,
we're fighting a
trend that I believe.
Watch this.
By show of hands, and remember
that lying is the devil,
how many people here are now
mad when another human being
calls them on the phone?
Raise your hand.
Raise it high.
This is super interesting now.
We're in a place now
where technology has gotten
into a place where
you don't understand
why somebody's calling you.
They should email or text you,
and you will get
back to them on your time.
I mean, literally.
And so,
we're just living through
a lot of changes in our...
Guys, this is the
single biggest culture shift
of communication in our
society in the last 70 years.
I mean, this is a big
deal, this transformation
to the internet age
and to the mobile age.
This is a major shift
and has massive repercussions
on our businesses.
- [Sara] I mean, what do you
think is the biggest opportunity
for credit unions right
now, given this mobile shift?
- Well first, very honestly,
what I'd like
to do is look
under the hood on a P&amp;L
in one of these
CEOs and understand
what they spend their money on
to try to make the thing that
they want to make happen.
So I think the
biggest opportunity is,
when's the last
time everybody here,
who runs one of
these businesses,
sat down and looked
at every dollar deployed
on people,
infrastructure, marketing,
the whole nine, and said what
does this penny do for me
to get to what I want.
The problem is
that 80% of the behavior
that is being done
by companies is things
that have been
accepted as tried and true,
or costs of business,
or just things
that they're accustomed to.
In that 80%, 50% of
that stuff is vulnerable.
I'd like to take that 50% and
get them to start using it
against modern
behavior that can lead
to a funnel of acquisition
of the kind of clientele
that they're
going to be looking for
for them to be in
business over the next decade.
That's what I would do.
Audit.
Who's got a question?
Where are the mics?
- Question here
for you, the audience,
does WineLibrary.com
have a mobile app?
No, so we're mobile optimized,
but we don't have a mobile app.
Truth be told,
it's really interesting.
We've A/B tested
that a little bit
but I'm not
running the business day in
and day out anymore,
and to air a little bit
of dirty laundry, my dad,
my dad is a cliche operator
that bothers me
the way he operates.
I'm not there every day.
It's a family business,
and as you can imagine,
there's an enormous emotion
around family businesses.
He ran it for a while.
I ran it for a while,
changed the
landscape of the business.
I'm doing other things,
and even though my dad knows
what I do for a living, and
grow other people's businesses,
he's pretty steadfast on
doing certain things the way
he wanted to do them.
It has not worked over
the last three or four years,
and now, finally, I'm back to
like, doing certain things.
So, like, that's
what's happening there.
- [Sara] Interesting.
This kind of reminds me of
when you were talking before
about like, so what the world
is change, just get with it.
- Right.
- Where's the point
where you throw the baby out
with the bathwater
in terms of wisdom that
that older generation brings,
and sort of like the way
we used to do things.
There is a wisdom that you have
to carry with you as you adapt.
Where's the line there for you?
- There's no blanket statement
that would answer this.
One more time, how
many CEOs in this room,
raise your hand.
You know, do I believe 50% of
these people should be fired?
Yes.
(audience laughter)
But I just don't
know which 50%, right?
And what I mean by
that is, in the scenario,
obviously I'm
going for shock effect,
with saying that to the people
that just raised their hands,
but the truth is,
it's the ones in this room
who've used
wisdom and convert it
into romance and being romantic
about how you do
things is the quickest way
to go out of business.
I just don't know
which ones are romantic
and only
leveraging wisdom, right,
and I don't know which ones
are just not knowledgeable,
what the alternatives
are and they're open to it,
but their partners
or their people
in their organization
haven't broken through to them
and put them in that position.
- [Sara] Yeah, has there
been a moment with you
and your father, where he has
sort of shown you the light
on something,
where you were like,
oh my new ways aren't working.
- Yeah, not when I...
So look, I mean, I
took over my dad's business.
It was doing $3 million
a year on 10% gross profit,
which means it was
making $300,000 before expenses,
and in five years,
with no cash infusion,
I grew it from
$3 to $65 million in revenue.
Like, I know what
the hell I'm doing.
But did my dad teach me things?
Of course, when
I was 16 years old,
my dad grabbed me
by the arm and said,
"You just bought
your first wine order,"
as a 16-year-old, bought a
bunch of cases of something.
And he looked at me and
said, "If you change your mind
"between today and
when the order comes in,
"you'll drink every
one of those bottles.
"You will not
cancel that order."
And he said (spits) this
is the most important thing
in life, and it was
the best piece of advice
I've ever given,
because, as you can tell,
I'm a more refined
version of myself at 40.
Imagine how full
of crap I was at 16.
So, so, so sure, but,
but, listen,
at the end of the day,
results are results, you know?
I knew what I was doing.
There's a reason the
business has been flat
since I've left.
There's a reason that
in the last four years,
that I've run
VaynerMedia it's grown
from $3 to
$100 million in revenue.
Like, I've got plenty at stake
along with the showmanship
that I deploy here on stage.
I just happen to do
both, but I, not really.
Most of the arguments
my dad and I had in
that eight year period,
where I really ran it,
I won almost every one of them.
That's just the truth.
Because my dad is
romantic and emotional,
and I'm not.
'Cause I know the market
doesn't give a crap about me.
- [Sara] Yeah, interesting.
- We have a question over here.
- [Man] Gary,
first a blatant suck up.
I agree with you
completely about the results
of 2008 to the current period,
but I think the reason is,
and with all due respect
to Co-op, that
we've got a bifurcated industry.
We have two trade organizations,
we have multiple
plastic card services,
networks, we don't talk
with one voice to
the American public.
There are 6500 credit unions.
We talk with 6500 plus voices
and we get lost in the noise.
- [Gary] I think that's an
easy way to pass on the buck.
My belief is that, one
of the top 10 credit unions
actually did the actions and
did the marketing themselves,
that they could have
dragged everybody along.
I mean, why didn't they?
The truth is, I don't
want to pontificate on stage.
I don't know, maybe they thought
that they were associated
with financial
institutions, I'm not sure.
Maybe it wasn't in their
financial vested interest,
maybe they didn't understand
how to make YouTube videos
and Google Adwords
during that time, I don't know.
But what I do know is
that it didn't happen.
And what I do know is
I've never seen a
co-op move an industry.
I've seen leaders within
the industry do something.
It worked and then
everybody followed it.
(audience applause)
- So we've spoken about,
on the negative side,
what they're not doing,
what's a company
in the financial services
sector doing a good job?
- I'm not sure.
What I know is this.
Here's what I know, and a lot
of this is headline reading,
and I'm scared of
that, so all my answers are
about to become
completely unofficial,
because I hate anointing things,
if I don't know
things under the hood.
But I do know from
a branding standpoint
that AmEX's Small
Business Saturday is the kind
of way we need to
be thinking about it.
Like, the data
that I've looked at,
and I don't know how
successful it was compared
to what they spent
against it to make it happen,
but when you look
at conversion rates
of small businesses
who are not happy
with how much
percentage AmEX takes,
and had a lot of energy
to push you towards Visa
and Mastercard, over
the last seven years,
of that Small Business
Saturday campaign,
they've been able
to win more accounts
in small businesses
around the country
on the branding that
they're small business friendly.
Even though they're
still taking 1.3% more
of the transaction
than their competitors.
So that, to me, is interesting.
That to me is interesting.
I think when you look at
a firm, a new organization
that let's people
pay on websites
in installments
instead of one transaction,
when you look at how
PayPal did customer acquisition,
there's things out there,
Mint, and things out there,
there's certain
things out there,
but the truth is I don't
spend a lot of time looking
at what people are doing
outside of me or my clients.
Even the
competitors of my clients.
So I'm not sure,
because my North Star
for doing something well isn't,
you liked their commercial,
or you liked their campaign,
or you thought this bank
or this credit union
did a nice job on Instagram.
I want to know what that
money that they spent on,
meant to their
bottom line as a business.
And without looking
under somebody's hood,
and understanding that,
I just don't know.
- [Scott] So would I be
right in saying you don't
currently have a
financial services client?
- So, we do, but
I'm under a lot of NDAs.
We have a new one,
a big one, we have one
of the three top banks.
We literally,
ironically today while I was
in the parking lot,
won a massive piece
of business from them.
We were working with one
of the top four credit
card companies in America.
We didn't see the
world the same way,
and I'm super rich already.
I don't need clients that
aren't gonna do the behavior
that is interesting
for me to learn from,
so that one ended.
- [Scott] Interesting.
Who here would like to be a
Gary Vaynerchuk client now?
(laughs)
(audience laughs)
- [Sara] There's a question.
- Question over here?
- [Man 2] Yeah,
Gary, you've indicated
that you think that
being emotional and a romantic
is a fatal flaw--
- Yes.
- [Man 2] in a business, but
that you rely heavily on
being empathetic.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Can you help me parse those
two concepts a little bit?
- [Gary] Yeah,
they're contradictions.
So, way to sniff it out.
(audience laughter)
You know, I think that,
I think that
way too many people,
when I say
emotional and romantic,
they are not respecting
what the market is doing.
I actually think they're
completely opposite things.
I use empathy to try to figure
out what the market is doing,
and then give them
what they want, and I define
being romantic and
emotional about things is,
something's happening that's
not in your best interest
in the market, but you
don't want it to happen,
so you create a delusional
conversation with yourself,
making pretend
it doesn't happen.
Or worse, and this
one really is a big one.
Or worse, you as a
human being recognize
that you're not
gonna be in that company
two or three years
from now, and taking money
and investing in the
logo's health in a decade
is gonna lower the margin
and profits for the company
over the next two years,
which means when you leave it,
you don't leave with
as much money personally
because you
weren't as profitable,
'cause you
invested into the future
that didn't have
immediate returns.
- Deep.
The room's gone silent.
- It's true.
It's true. There are a
lot of CEOs that run companies
that know that they're not gonna
be there in 24 to 36 months
that know the math
behind their bonuses,
which are completely
based on P&amp;L profit,
and to be successful
in six years from today,
you need to deploy money
to have the infrastructure
and the capabilities
for six years from today.
The problem is, you're
gonna be on your yacht,
or playing golf, and so you
don't personally get benefited
for the investment in the
company, so you, as a human,
and I don't blame you,
humans are flawed,
do behavior that's in your best
interest as Rick and Sally,
not in the best
interest of XYZ Credit Union.
That's real.
Like, that's real.
- [Sara] So what, what
would you say would be--
- By the way, that's
why so much doesn't happen.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- It's just real.
- [Sara] I'm glad you
stood up for that.
- Thanks.
- I think that was important.
- I think it's important,
and by the way,
and I'm gonna say this,
who am I to judge?
I don't get to judge.
I'm not judging you.
I'm just telling you
what's happening in the game,
and you all know it.
- [Sara] So we talked a little
bit about, I mean, just to sort
of bring this back into
practical application
a little bit,
if you were sitting in the
CEO position at a credit union
and you were thinking,
I'm out of here
in two to three years,
but I need to invest
a decade from now,
what would you do?
- The first thing
I would do, back to that safe,
selfish human behavior,
is understand that
if I did everything right over
the next two or three years,
I'd probably sit on
three really good boards
of public companies and make
a hell of a lot more money
than what I was trying to
milk out of my own company
over the next three years.
- [Sara] Okay.
- That's number one.
- [Sara] That's practical.
- Look, doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
You know, we're just always
looking in short-term behavior.
All the vig, the
arbitrage that I live in,
is I'm doing
marathon running behavior
in a world of sprinters.
I understand the
energy I deploy on stage,
but let me un-confuse you.
I am a tortoise
in a hare's costume.
(audience laughter)
That was interesting. (coughs)
But that's what I am.
Like, my decision
making is based on
what I think consumers
are gonna be doing today,
and, not just today,
and in 24, 36, 48 months,
and I run my
organizations based on that.
That's what
I think a CEO should do.
While you're getting
paid and running a company,
you need to
think about the company
not only in the short
term, but in the long term,
and you have to make
those financial bets,
and you have to
create the infrastructure
for your organization
to do those things,
because if you do it, you
will be rewarded historically
by the market of
doing smart things,
which will then lead
to enormous upside for you
in the world post your being
the active CEO of that company
with all the other
benefits that the business world
grants you when you
are historically correct.
I don't get to sit up here
and get paid a lot of money
to do speaking
engagements 'cause I'm razzy,
or I make a joke,
or I'm confrontational.
It's 'cause I have results.
- [Sara] And 'cause
you're razzy, and you're fun.
(audience laughter)
- Sure, I mean, you know what?
That's the nice to have.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- But the punch line,
and you know this,
the punch line is,
seven years ago,
when everybody was
a social media expert,
I'm the one who emerged
and built an actual business.
I'm the one that Toyota and
GE and Unilever is thrilled
to point to and say,
they helped our business, too.
I'm the one who sells
hundreds of thousands of books
in the first week when
other social media experts
that try to sell you
social media advice come out
with a book and sell a
thousand copies in four months,
shouldn't have they used their
advice to sell their book?
(audience laughter)
- [Sara] Sure.
So, I mean, bringing it
back home, what was something
you did seven years ago--
- [Gary] Sorry, that's just a
personal angry moment.
Go ahead.
(laughter)
- What was something
you did seven years ago
that people were looking
at you like, that's crazy,
but you're thinking,--
- [Gary] Everything,
- [Gary] Everything
I've ever done in my life.
- I'm investing in the future.
- [Gary] In 1996, when
I launched the third
e-commerce wine
business in America,
people laughed at my
dad for letting their kid
ruin his business.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- Guys, 20 years
ago, a lot of you thought
the internet was a fad.
Let's just cut to the chase.
If you even knew what it was.
When I bought
Google Adwords, my dad,
it was the only thing
my dad ever fought me on.
He didn't want me to
do it, 'cause he told me
our competitors
were gonna click our ads
and make us pay for ads that
we weren't gonna convert.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- When I started my
YouTube show four months
after YouTube started,
when nobody in the world
knew what it was, and
I was sitting in front of it,
tasting wine and
creating content,
and bringing value to people,
my entire organization
thought I lost my mind.
They didn't know
what YouTube was.
When I invested in, and
then spent 10 hours a day
on Twitter in 2007 and eight,
everybody thought I was stupid.
- [Sara] So, I mean, it sounds
to me like, when we drill down,
it's not so much,
I'm in short-term thinking,
I want to sit on my yacht,
but it takes a lot of courage
to be doing the thing, to be
sitting in front of the camera,
and everyone
thinks you're nuts, right?
And so,--
- [Gary] Sure.
- how do we instill,
you know, a more bold,
a boldness in ourselves?
- [Gary] Sitting in front of the
camera's a different thing,
'cause you have to have
the vanity and other things
that one would need to
put themselves out there,
and I recognize those traits.
The Twitter
thing's more interesting.
I thought it was
gonna be important,
and so I put the time
to become a practitioner,
not a headline reader, so it
doesn't take courage to do it.
It takes time.
- [Sara] Time.
- It takes time, and I promise
you, if the CEOs in this room
audited what they do with
their time, they could find
20% of it that's being
spent on ludicrous stuff
that doesn't bring
any more value anymore,
and they could deploy that
to learning this new world,
and then becoming
practitioners so that she and he
can be the judge
and jury of the partners
and the heads of marketing,
and actually hold them
to a standard that
needs to be held to
in today's environment.
Guys, technology
is not a sector.
Technology is all-encompassing.
This is not a nice
to have or a division.
This is the
world we now live in.
It's going to eat up everything.
It got to book stores early.
It's gotten to hotels
and taxis and limos recently.
It's going to get to everything.
Just a matter of time.
- [Scott] There is not one part
of a credit union--
- Yeah, let's get
this gentleman's question.
- [Man 3] I just have a
statement not a question.
- Okay.
- [Man 3] I'm a CEO
of a credit union,
and we do think long-term.
- Yes.
- [Man 3] This is not the
American Bankers Association.
- Yes.
- [Man 3] And we do think
long-term.
- Yes.
- Bankers do think quarter,
by quarter, by quarter,
so that's number one.
Number two, there is a
missed opportunity--
- [Gary] And
real quick, my friend,
I don't think in the
advice that you're giving people
because I'm grounded in that.
I mean, in running the
business that we're--
- [Man 3] I understand that.
- Okay.
- Right, and so
I've got two branches
that won't be profitable
until after I'm gone.
- [Gary] Right.
- Okay, and you know,
we're not thinking--
- [Gary] Respect.
- We're not thinking
short-terms.
- [Gary] Respect.
- So the other thing is in 2008,
there was a missed opportunity.
It's back. Okay?
And the reason is
because it's election year.
Secondly,
Big Short you mentioned.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Everybody
understood that, right?
- [Gary] Yes.
- So, election year, Big Short,
the budget deal in 2015--
- [Gary] Yes.
- In December, the bankers
pulled Dodd-Frank out.
Everybody missed it.
So if we had one
voice speaking about that,
we've got another opportunity.
So I just want to
let you know that.
We are bifurcated.
I do believe that, too,
and that's a problem,
but if we did have one voice--
- [Gary] Yes.
- That went after this--
- The American public
would understand that so--
- Well, let's stay on
this because I agree with you.
- [Man 3] Sure.
- And I appreciate the
energy you are bringing.
- [Man 3] Sure.
Yesterday, a hundred
different videos on Facebook,
with no money whatsoever,
hundreds of dollars
of ad placement,
reached over ten million
people on organic virality
based on its subject matter.
Your ability tomorrow as an
organization to make a video
on this story to
educate the American people,
without any of your
friends in here joining you,
spending $1,000,
$2,000 to produce it,
whether you, and I think
you come across great,
so if you want to do it,
or if somebody else
wants to do it, fine,
and then spending
another $2,000 on ad spend
against fans of Bernie Sanders,
fans of Donald Trump,
fans of Hillary,
you know the political,
or other
different segmentations,
fans of banks, fans of
organizations, fight the bank,
America for this, what have you,
all segmentations that
you can target on Facebook.
If you did that
five, seven, eight times,
if you get one that
goes viral, Mazel Tov.
You've won.
If not, if you spent a couple
of hundred thousand dollars,
you could blanket
the entire country
and give them that message.
That's what I'm
passionate about.
Which is that, it doesn't
cost a lot of money in 2017
to hit the American people,
it's just that we're not
respecting the marketing tactics
that can get us there.
- [Man 3] I agree, and
I'll just finish with this,
that, again, we're
not short-term thinkers,
we're long-term, and finally,
bring back Glass-Steagall,
and stop talking about taxation.
You may not
understand what I just said,
but I think the
rest of the room did.
Bring back Glass-Steagall.
Attack the bankers because
I'm tired of getting attacked.
- [Gary] Good for you.
Good luck.
- [Scott] I want to add on that.
So one trend--
(audience applause)
- When that, can you
bring that gentleman back?
I have a real question
because I'm actually curious
for my own education,
when he says
he's tired of getting attacked,
is there a feeling
within the industry
that the American,
that the end consumer,
Sir, when you said --
- [Man 3] Yes.
- You're tired of getting
attacked--
- [Man 3] Do you want me
to come up and sit down?
- I'm sorry?
- [Man 3] You want me
to come up and sit down?
- Yeah! Hell yeah!
(laughing)
- When you said you're,
I was fascinated
by that end statement.
When you said you're tired
of getting attacked--
- [Man 3] Yes.
- do you feel that
the American consumer
has the credit
unions in that position?
- [Man 3] No.
- Okay.
- [Man 3] I think the,
long since,
it's like they've
habituated to that message,
but we have a
huge opportunity here.
This is all going on
right now where bankers,
they've got no firewall
between deposits and loans--
- [Gary] Right.
- And selling it
off to the world.
- [Gary] Right.
- It's, nothing's changed.
- [Gary] No, listen--
- Nothing.
- You're preaching.
I made a reference about
I can't wait for the next one,
and real quick,
just for my own education
because I'm curious,
when you said, "I'm
tired of being attacked."
- [Man 3] Yeah, the debate
between banks and credit unions
is all about taxation,
which is
meaningless to everybody.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- [Gary] I --
- It's 2.7 billion
to the treasury.
- [Gary] Right.
- Which is a teardrop,
but think of how much money
the banks cost American people.
- [Gary] You're preaching.
- And the message
is not getting out.
- [Gary] Do you
think any normal American
knows about this debate between
the credit unions and banks?
- I think they understand
that banks created it.
I think there's a message
problem with regards to
getting that message
out to the American people
from the credit union industry.
It's not there.
It's empty. Zip.
And it's huge.
- [Sara] I think that--
- [Scott] The opportunity here
is, so there is actually
a large movement,
it's primarily coming
out of Canada at the moment,
of a consumer movement
back against the ethics
of how banks make money.
The reality is Gary
has a spare thousand bucks.
I need a thousand bucks.
There's this other
company in between
that makes that
transaction happen,
and so that particularly
unsecured lending space,
the ethics of how
much margin they make
to make that transaction
is getting questioned
in a number of markets.
There is a 13 year old girl
that has an
amazing YouTube video
that questions how banks make
money on unsecured lending.
That has created
a whole tidal wave
of consumer negative sentiment
around how banks make money,
which is why if you ever look at
the most successful
Fin Tech startups today,
they're all about "how do
we connect to individuals?"
- Of course.
- Peer to peer lending. It's
peer to peer foreign exchange.
- But I think it's dangerous,
the context of me saying,
"We missed an opportunity."
It's not about
bashing the banks,
it's about getting
people to understand
what we bring to the table.
- [Sara] Yeah.
- This is not a we need to
spend money bashing them out,
or amplifying that 13
year old girl's video.
It's how are we communicating
to the end consumer
to create consideration
for me to give you my money
versus the alternatives
that have out-marketed
and out-positioned
your organizations
in the marketplace,
and to me, when you
look at what's happening
in marketing today, the brands,
and this is happening absolutely
in the political races,
everyone's like, "How is this
all, how did Obama happen?"
"How is this
Trump thing happening?"
Easy.
They're using the
things I'm talking about.
This is not complicated, right?
How did Under Armour
catch up to Nike?
Easy.
They're using the
things that I'm talking about.
How did Honest Company and
Method become real competitors
with Johnson &amp; Johnson
and Unilever
and Procter and Gamble?
Easy. They're using the
things that I'm talking about.
So it's about the opportunities
in a digital environment
to create content
and target people
with the messaging
that we want them to know.
That tactic, and
understanding that religion,
is the white space.
- [Sara] Yeah, so I'm going to--
- [Scott] Why don't we get to,
Sam would actually love this,
the message you want
to tell your consumer is,
Sam already put it up in the
very first purpose video,
that should be your brand.
That was an amazing video, Sam.
I applaud you, Sam.
Sorry, Gary.
It's all about the
purpose of a credit union,
but that is the brand.
That's the narrative you need
to make the market understand.
It's already there.
- Or, real quick,
because I'll just leave
a tactical thing
for you, it's not.
We don't know,
but you can spend very
little money deploying this
in a Facebook video environment,
and reaching tens
of millions of people,
and seeing how they
react to it in the comments,
qualitative feedback at scale,
and you can make
forty different messages.
Like, for the credit union,
you guys don't
need the milk campaign.
You don't need one shining star
that's going to save it all.
You need to have a process
that makes
eighty-seven different
potential stories and videos
go through the
Facebook environment
that has hundreds of
millions of users on it,
and see what people react to,
and then triple down on that.
- Yeah.
- Got it?
- Yeah. I'm going
to stop us here,
but I think that is
a great place to end.
There's, I think,
limitless opportunity.
I have sort of a
glass-half-full here,
and I appreciate those comments,
and you've certainly given
us a lot of food for thought,
so we're going to take
some time to chomp on that.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
- [Gary] Thank you, guys.
Thank you for having me.
(audience applause)
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)